how's it going everybody so about a week
ago or so Marvel's Avengers infinity war
the art of the movie book came out and
it's really awesome and has some amazing
things inside of the book amazing photos
of alternate costume designs for some
characters and even some alternate
scenes there have been a lot of videos
done on these alternate scenes and even
the alternate ending I've done to myself
they're actually pretty cool but some of
the most interesting things in this book
actually come from the commentary that's
inside of it and I want to talk about a
specific commentary by co-writer
Christopher Markus that could offer some
insight in how the Avengers could
potentially defeat Thanos and Avengers 4
also I'm still doing my giveaway giving
away copies of Infinity Ward Deadpool 2
and ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray as
well as some special edition posters if
you would like to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero so as I
mentioned this commentary is in the book
and it's by co-writer of infinity war an
Avengers for Christopher Markus and it's
about the Infinity stones and it's about
Thanos so this is what he says in the
commentary
they've been misused by people who
didn't understand their true power and
now that the real master of them Thanos
has showed up we can see what they
actually do the problem is as you can
imagine as you gain control over these
things your story just goes haywire
because why are there any stakes for the
man who can control time-space reality
your mind your soul and power he can
reset as many times as it'll take so you
have to build in a lot of bumps in the
road or maybe keep one stone away from
him for long enough in order for the
thing to have any dramatic structure at
all okay so a few things to talk about
in the beginning he says they've been
misused by people who didn't understand
their true power which is true we have
seen the stones be used throughout the
MCU and all of which besides Doctor
Strange have definitely not really fully
grasped their power so we think about
Loki Red Skull Ronan the accuser Ultron
nobody has been able to harness the
power of the Infinity stones quite like
vanos after all danos did hold them with
his bare hands so we finally have
someone who can fully control the stones
as power and this is where
Christopher Markus says in the
commentary that the story goes haywire
because how can you defeat somebody who
essentially has control over reality and
the universe and that's where
Christopher Markus says there has to be
some sort of bump in the road or the
Avengers have to get a stone away from
him for them to even have a chance so
when I think about the first part a bump
in the road I think about the Infinity
Gauntlet being destroyed at the end of
infinity war so coming from a writer's
perspective which Christopher Markus is
because he co-wrote the film you look at
the Infinity Gauntlet and you think how
could the Avengers defeat this and the
answer was you damage it during a Q&A on
Twitter the Russo brothers said that
there was a cost to Thanos doing the
snap and they said that both fan OHS and
the Infinity Gauntlet were both
permanently damaged after the snap
Thanos can clearly still use the
Infinity stones because we saw him use
the space stone to get away from Thor at
the end of the movie but what they're
saying here is that the Infinity
Gauntlet can't perform another snap
Thanos can't alter the universe at will
anymore but he does still have the other
stones including the time stone and a
space stone he could possibly use the
time stone to repair the Infinity
Gauntlet and he could possibly use the
space stone to travel to neduvaali R to
get a new Infinity Gauntlet which is
where the second part of what
Christopher Markus is saying comes in
where you have to get a stone away from
him Thanos needs all six of the Infinity
stones to perform another snap and
essentially have control over the
universe and if you get a single stone
away from him he no longer has that
power so the key to defeating Thanos is
to get one of the Infinity stones away
from him this stone could possibly be
the time stone after all we know that
time travel is going to play a pretty
big part in Avengers 4 Doctor Strange
was pretty adamant about not letting
Thanos get a hold of the time stone
throughout the whole entire movie but
then at the end he gave it up pretty
easily so perhaps he saw that the
Avengers somehow get it back whether
they used the time stone themselves to
go back in time or they used a quantum
realm it's certainly beneficial for
Thanos to not have the time stone not
only will he not be able to go back
through time but he won't have all six
Infinity stones giving him complete
power over everything so getting one of
the Infinity stones away from Thanos is
going to be the key to defeating him in
Avengers 4 sounds like a job for an
Avenger that nobody can really see I
love meeting people
I love it yeah what do you guys do so
let me know what you think about
Christopher Marcus's commentary in the
artbook and let me know which infinity
stone you think the Avengers are going
to take back from Thanos let me know
what you think in the comments below and
again don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]